digamos que con este diagrama que nos
muestran aquí sabemos que el lado ave es
igual al lado hace este lado de aquí a b
tiene la misma longitud que el lado hace
estos dos son iguales
y también nos dicen que el ángulo
efe efe este ángulo de acá es igual al
ángulo a c y este ángulo de acá lo
primero que intentaré probar aquí es si
el segmento b efe
efe este segmento de aquí
o el lado b efe vamos a escribir lo
bonito de f es igual al lado c
a este de aquí eso es lo que quiero
probar por sostienen los signos de
interrogación
usemos nuestras dos columnas en caso de
que esto lo vean en clase sepan cómo
hacer este tipo de demostraciones
tendremos en este lado
vamos a dibujar nuestras columnas
nuestras dos columnas
y así rápido de este lado escribimos el
enunciado o los enunciados
enunciado
y de este otro lado escribimos las
razones que apoyan ese enunciado razón
vamos a escribir esta información que
nos han dado en ambas columnas nuestro
primer enunciado
nos dice que el lado ave
es igual al lado a c y la razón es obvia
no las están dando como especificaciones
de este problema nuestro segundo
anunciado nos dice que el ángulo
efe
es igual al ángulo
y lo mismo la razón es porque está dado
en la especificación de este problema
está aquí algo interesante es que
tenemos un ángulo y un lado en cada uno
de estos triángulos estos triángulos que
estoy mostrando aquí y aquí
podemos ver que ambos triángulos el
triángulo bf y el triángulo ace
ambos comparten el vértice
podemos decir como tercer afirmación
nuestro tercer enunciado dice que
nuestro ángulo b
de hace es igual al ángulo de ave
a ver la abertura es la misma no importa
en qué orden estemos poniendo las
etiquetas esta abertura es la misma la
razón de esta afirmación es obvio obvio
y y lo pongo entre paréntesis que es la
propiedad reflectiva
propiedad propiedad
reflectiva
muy bien y aquí sucede algo interesante
tenemos un ángulo un lado y otro ángulo
así que por ángulo lado ángulo tenemos
que nuestra cuarta afirmación nuestra
cuarta afirmación
el triángulo ve a efe este triángulo de
aquí que voy a poner en un color azul
más oscuro ve a efe
es este triángulo que estoy digamos que
rodeando
este triángulo de acá de f
efe bonita será congruente
será congruente congruente con el
triángulo se a
qué es este triángulo que voy
rodear con esta línea punteada color
rosa rosa más o menos fresa
ok aquí está
y la razón de esta afirmación viene de
ángulo lado ángulo que está apoyada por
los enunciados 1 2 y 3
ya que sabemos que estos triángulos son
congruentes también sabemos que sus
lados van a ser congruentes por lo que
nuestra quinta afirmación o nuestro
quinto enunciado enunciado 5
es que el lado de f
va a ser igual al lado c
ve
es igual a 12 en estos dos que justo es
lo que queríamos probar así que esto
está apoyado por nuestro cuarto
enunciado con lados correspondientes que
son congruentes las dos correspondientes
ahora hagamos otra demostración vamos a
tratar de probar que el segmento de este
segmento de aquí es igual al segmento d
efe a este otro segmento de acá así que
nuestra otra afirmación bueno nuestra
otra pregunta que trataremos de
responder la voy a escribir por acá es
si mi segmento
ed
es igual a mi segmento de efe y aquí
tenemos otra interrogación
al principio puede no ser obvio el
encontrar algún tipo de congruencia aquí
pero ya contamos con cierto tipo de
información sabemos que de a efe este
triángulo es congruente con este otro
triángulo de acá con otro triángulo se a
y también sabemos qué
este lado que voy a usar en un voy a
remarcar en otro color sabemos que este
lado de aquí este lado de aquí
el segmento
este de acá va a ser congruente con el
segmento a efe este segmento que voy a
remarcar aquí espero se note aquí el
segmento a efe estos dos van a ser
iguales así que nuestro sexto enunciado
sexto enunciado establece que el
segmento a es igual al segmento
efe
esto está respaldado igual que arriba
por el enunciado 4 por la 2
correspondientes
que son congruentes congruentes los de
arriba también son congruentes
lados correspondientes vamos a quitar
esto de aquí correspondientes
congruentes esto es importante ponerlo
congruentes
y cerramos paréntesis muy bien el que
estos dos segmentos sean congruentes nos
ayuda con esta parte de aquí abajo ya
que sabemos qué
a b es igual a ace por lo tanto el
segmento de nuestro enunciado 7 el
segmento b
de aquí a acá
va a ser igual al segmento c efe este de
aquí acá c
efe y esto está apoyado por que ven
es igual a ave menos
que esto a su vez es igual
hace menos a efe
y esto a su vez es igual a c efe
este segmento le quitamos
este segmento de acá y nos queda este y
como estos dos son iguales hacemos la
misma operación y nos queda entonces que
este segmento b es igual al segmento c
efe
y esto es por los enunciados 1 y 6 así
que este segmento de acá el b
es igual al segmento fcc o cf estos dos
son iguales este y este
otra cosa que sabemos es que debido a
los ángulos verticales a los ángulos
verticales
el ángulo debe este ángulo de acá que
voy a marcar con una etiqueta de este
ángulo de acá será congruente con el
ángulo fdc este ángulo de acá nuestro
octavo lo voy a escribir por acá nuestro
octavo enunciado
es que el ángulo
de b
igual al ángulo efe de c y esto es por
los ángulos ángulos verticales
y que les congruentes
verticales congruentes
ahora de nuevo nos encontramos con algo
muy interesante tenemos este ángulo
naranja tenemos el ángulo azul y tenemos
este lado naranja
sabemos que estos dos triángulos más
pequeños que voy a remarcar en colores
diferentes son congruentes este
triángulo
d
estoy haciendo aquí el remarcado medio
extraño pero es para que se note este
triángulo de nuestro noveno en su
enunciado el triángulo
de b
es congruente es congruente con nuestro
triángulo cfd c
efe
d
estoy poniendo aquí el triángulo cf d
y esto es debido a la congruencia ángulo
ángulo la congruencia
congruencia
y ya que demostremos que este triángulo
es congruente con este otro pues
entonces sabemos que todos sus lados son
congruentes y ya estábamos por llegar al
final este lado de acá el lado ed
este de acá es congruente y por lo tanto
es igual al lado de efe que tenemos acá
nuestro décimo y último enunciado el
lado ed
es igual al lado de efe y esto se debe
al enunciado 9 que implica la dos lados
correspondientes
correspondientes congruentes
con esto terminamos este fue un problema
algo denso pero si vamos paso a paso
tratando de averiguar lo más que podamos
de cada triángulo y eventualmente pues
llegaremos a la respuesta correcta
en realidad la parte más difícil es ver
los triángulos correctos aquí por
ejemplo saber que obtenemos hebe de
restar
de ave
o ver que hay dos triángulos
trasladándose aquí en estos brazos